is this going to do
it this should do
it I'm going
to please be working already
please I'm going to give a YouTube a
good spanking for this like twitch
you just click one button and you're
done but why it has to be like this I
have no
idea
[Music]
it's not even showing up
anywhere it's most definitely
live what if I nope
nope just doesn't show
up um neither those it show up over
there okay it does never
mind do I see it over here
somewhere
[Music]
I don't think I
do
mhm oh that's sort of
it's most so it's just
live
[Music]
it is live but where the do I even
find it then
I'm going to I'm going to really spank
you for this okay I'm just going to
log out and see if I can find it
anywhere um I mean the worst thing that
could happen is that I can't reply to
comments but at least I should be able
to find it
right and ah there we go so it does show
up okay so for some reason it doesn't
show up when I try to find it myself
there we
go this is so not better than twitch um
thing is though like I felt like the
let's play is on YouTube so if I wanted
to do this live streaming thing on
YouTube oh I'm sorry guys seeing
comments as people saying like oh you
are live but I couldn't see
that that was a good
start um yeah I don't I don't think you
can even cut that out because YouTube's
editor doesn't let you edit a
video that's larger than 2 hours like
does YouTube just want to be inferior to
Twitch in any case hi everyone um that's
a pretty long list to even work on and
in the midst of all that stupid trying
to get this thing to work I don't even
have my Park loaded excellent just
amazing I already see too many problems
like I can't read back on the times that
things have been posted either and is it
refreshing or
not um okay it
is well that's a good thing at
least that was the most awkward sort of
start ever like I thought that was
really alone and that it didn't even
work for some
time damn it yeah this is why I don't
use YouTube usually for this sort of
thing but um I wanted to get this
archived instantly and um get that great
evening yeah before I have to go to
schol tomorrow
that it was not that bad well there's
there's too many reasons that I want to
use twitch over YouTube I mean there's
the copyrighted music too like you can't
even play any sort of thing on YouTube
without just getting completely silenced
getting strikes and all that I mean
sure you do get like after the stream it
does get muted if they have copyrighted
music but it doesn't mute the entire
thing it just it just mutes that one
section with the music which it doesn't
want to be played whereas in YouTube you
would have like an 8 hour video where
you would play like Nicki Minaj super
base once and then the entire
video would be muted just
no yeah it feel like that's one thing I
mean if it wasn't for the Mario Galaxy
music existing I wouldn't have done this
like music is too important to me I
can't just have that non-copyright
music going on that is not my
thing whatsoever
I not all the Galaxy tracks are that
dramatic plus it's it's awfully dramatic
because the loading screen is just the
most boring thing
ever also it's way too hot and my pants
are wet I just came from the station and
like some dick driver in a car he
decided to just no go four speeed ahead
and um it's it had rained so that wasn't
a good day
yeah we're almost there there we
go funny thing is I don't even have too
much of a planning of what I wanted to
do in this
episode um so that's going to probably
not become the best sort of thing ever
uh but oh well it's actually working on
my laptop like it seems to be frozen to
me I don't know I mean it's stuck on uh
what post activating 80% it's always
stuck on
that it's been a while that I've even
played this park without recording it
with reps that's a new
thing and yeah I'm just going to have to
focus on uh whatever I'm building really
trying to get my mind set on that okay
it is working
good oh there we go and yeah I did start
so late because all that happened like
no idea what was going on with all
that stupid thing it's going to feel
back it's going to feel good to be back
on Twitch again really um in any case I
really need to start working on some
stuff over here damn it when I stopped
that one stream I had some good ideas
but now I'm not even sure what to do
with this
area um it's okay Jared's here okay that
is good there there is actually
sometimes planning quite a bit quite a
bit sometimes if I really need it
um but today there is just no planning
whatsoever which might become a tiny bit
of a problem I'm not even sure what I
want to do with the pathworks over here
honestly yeah do I just want to head off
and actually finish that for a tiny bit
because it's just looking like no I
don't want to have it I don't want to
have grass over
there I can find the set there we go for
some reason I always lose this set
and I always lose the one brick that I
use in
[Music]
it this was supposed to not be a
sing long stream what
what Kitty swings are the best
swings um I'm not too sure about having
it like that
though no no no no no
no much rather have something on top of
that but
I'm going to have to find other path
covers for
that this is the best theme at least I
think
[Music]
so nothing is really as good as a good
old worlds I
suppose no there is planning sometimes
sometimes I really just need
it yeah I'm not going to do pathwork for
this thing or maybe at least not as much
that's going to be quite a challenge but
I don't want to riddle the park with all
sorts of collors so this might be the
best thing to kind of go for in here I'm
going to just destroy the magic over
here um I'm probably not going to build
a new coaster yet I mean I don't know
how far I'll get with this but after
this I would like to move on to the
English section soon and find out a
layout for that and since the Coter is
going to play a pretty large role the
coaster is one of the first things that
that I want to do in the English area
along along with the well very important
pathwork but yeah I'm going to destroy
the Magic in this episode like on the
time lapses it always seems like I know
what I'm doing but reality is I really
don't
H but yeah that certainly doesn't look
like what I want to go
for and for some reason it just doesn't
want to remove things in a way that
makes
sense
what come on please don't do this to me
come on thank you not even sure what's
like the hitbox problem I think it is
still this thing pretty sure it is like
actually it isn't it can't be cuz it
would show a message of that
H I will make a no I'm not going to have
one of those because they're like really
cheap coasters and this is supposed to
be a not so very cheap
Park I will have that lbrand c a coaster
except I won't like how do you even
theme that
thing Six Flags doesn't have to worry
about that but I
do
H this pathwork looks so incredibly dark
yeah I don't think I'm going to go with
this I'm just yeah that's the problems
that I
get freaking hit boxes every single
thing has a hit box that's larger than
life well that was not what I was trying
to do oh well actually helped turn out
that that little thing was causing the
hitbox problems so that's all right just
need to find that thing
again
I won't build one no
never is not even the right color I
think that is brown right
there yep there we
go and yeah I would like to replace that
thing I think I'm just going to go with
the same color as these path covers
since they do work they do have a nice
Synergy with the colors of these and
already have them over here so that
should be a tiny bit of a more safe
option to go with
here if I can find that thing must be in
junior rides there we
go um why do I want
this not even
sure I don't think I can place it
anywhere but like over here
going to remove that
anyway I don't care about functionality
it has to look
good yeah YouTube
sucks um this is roller coaster I
three um not Minecraft as some people
like you to believe
yeah this is a really good texture pack
like it's so good it like makes
everything look not blocky
anymore H in before I actually do a
Minecraft live
stream is this actually the same color
as that yeah there we go but it's also
the same color
as oh aha that's actually a good
idea though
bump all that I'm going to just go with
this
path and uh get some artwork on
that see I can't place things for
keep Miss Missing
everything oh there we
go I like Minecraft it's just uh the
community that I'm not really into
anymore but it's a good
game
[Music]
H now see the only problem that I have
with this is that it's just extremely
light it's more as a sort of sidewalk
thing
really um so yeah I'm going to have to
sort of cover that with different things
over there wait a second wait one second
right here if I go to mobies and get
those maybe even these
that could look
better I think I think I do want to go
for
that
H maybe even larger just slightly around
that thing
[Music]
too
yeah I'm not sure about
that and hi food an by the
way yeah see that's you know I I guess I
can turn this into little Minecraft talk
remove that thing again I'm such an
idiot um like I like the game it's sort
of similar in a way to roller coaster 3
at least if you play it for a creative
mode um though I like it more in
survival mode but building things in
survival mode for the challenge that it
brings of trying to gather the resources
but it's similar in a way since it is
also quite a creative game um but yeah
the thing is it's just so oversaturated
there's too many things about Minecrafts
on YouTube you just can't escape it it's
like minions of the gaming world
except minions are more like the
Minecraft of the real life
world yeah I think I'm just going to go
for it like this and then see if I can
get any sort of good
looking solution for this thing a jig
and make that come out right
eventually yep it's going to have to be
like that I have no idea how to actually
do this
otherwise I mean it doesn't even matter
that much as long as it good as long as
it looks good from the the side really
um so I shouldn't worry about it too
much but I do want to get the path Works
done in a way that I feel all right
[Music]
about
yep I usually just stream on Twitch but
now I do it on um YouTube because
YouTube is the best okay I'm not going
to like devolve this entire stream into
on the medium that I'm using at
the moment but it's um since the let's
play is on YouTube The Stream just had
to be on YouTube as well and instantly
archived and all that
stuff and it's a more accessible really
since you know I've got like 800
followers in twitch 7,000 subscribers on
YouTube and holy thank you I didn't
even think of that congratulations with
the thousandth episode I mean 100th damn
it what I think of you okay what I what
I think of RCT world I can't even talk
at the moment I'm sorry
um there's too much to talk about that
to really why do I have the as fa oh
this is concrete all right um there's
too much to really talk about to really
give it to you like in a couple minutes
but um I'm actually pretty positive at
the moment I was very cynical up until a
couple of days ago up until yesterday
actually um but yesterday I actually saw
that live stream from Alienware which
was really awesome and matlb and another
guy were actually live there playing the
game and I was actually pretty happy
about
that chat is better than twitch well
sort of since you do have the profile
pictures which I do like but other than
that I'm not a big fan of it plus I
can't really get an overlay with the
chat on screen with chroma keying and
stuff like that it's also a bit of a
shame but um yeah I'm happy about roller
coaster second world it really looks
like they've got the core down in a good
way um also you can clearly see that I
can't concentrate and talk about things
at the same time I can't even okay um
but there's a number of problems that I
really still have like um I said
actually in that stream I asked why The
Coasters would fly off the rails because
that's something which is actually sort
of proud proud of at the moment like um
where your coaster goes too fast it
flies off the rails which just
realistically doesn't happen like that a
thing that just it can't since there are
wheels all around the rails and if it
does happen you don't have all six cars
of a train derailing at the same time um
but that is in the game for some reason
and he just kind of shrugged that away
as yeah it's Roller Coaster Tycoon and
that's how roller coaster is but I hope
that's going to be at least like you're
going to be at least able to turn that
off but that's one of the least of my
worries I saw the win and coaster
supports actually 2D not just 3D Box
model so they're kind of like roller
coaster ATT 3
uh which is also quite a shame really
and yeah I wasn't really too happy about
seeing that either and but the general
point is it does look like an amazing
game and I really like it so far but it
just doesn't look polished or clean
enough yet to be released sometime this
year which is what they're going for and
I'm not sure if they should really do
[Music]
that
um I have actually by the way played
Minecraft a lot in my life um hundreds
of hours probably in that
game but um I just don't like to like I
still like to play it I just don't like
to make videos of it and I'm really
leaning towards the same thing with SK
City skylines at the moment I have
played it even for a couple of hours
today um but I don't know about making
videos of
it a coaster I don't think um yeah um I
want to have a coaster in the English
area which is something that I might get
to in this stream I'm not sure how far
I'm going to get with all this but um
the only problem with that is
that yeah I don't think how far I'll get
with that it's going to be part of the
planning of the English area to also
finish a coaster in
there but that is not really something
that I'm working towards
yet H I might want to revise the colors
on this though it's t of bit dark at the
moment
but it does look all
right I suppose such a simple thing um
plus I still need to get the fenes in
here too not even sure what sort of fet
I would like to use for this how I could
even build
it um most likely one of the branches
that's really most versatile
[Music]
anyway yeah this a bit Overkill though
yeah
true you know what I have actually a
better idea I'm going to try to get this
in later first just get in the booth and
the queue and the exit and all that
stuff and work around it and do the path
art as a later stage thing maybe even
when I finish the details of the
restaurant
really but I'm not going to do too much
to this thing really it's really small
and not too important so it's just going
to have a simple little curved railing
around it I'd
say and I think I wouldn't one would
just do
here it's not too sure the colors
[Music]
there it works all right
though that's also hard to get the
entrance in then uh how do I do that
[Music]
that could actually
work not wouldn't be too bad
really um though I would probably like
to do it in a different
way kind a bit different if I
can how would I do
that yeah like over there and then make
that a
curve and make the q line around
it I'm way too big of a fan of this
soundtrack it's so
good that sort of idea I just need to
find a little segue into this thing
here
[Music]
is it isn't that like the entire the
entirety of YouTube Minecraft this sucks
an
Overkill no actually no forgot about def
find
[Music]
Bros twitch chats I don't know it it
really sort of depends what sort of
stream you go to really
I mean when you go to like one of the
big channels that's the thing I really
don't even understand about big channels
and twitch I don't understand why people
are even remotely interested in it
though that's just a personal thing I
just feel like twitch is a interactive
medium um but whenever somebody has a
thousand viewers where is the
interaction really I don't see much
interaction in that um so yeah I don't
see why people really like to watch
that and then you just got dumb people
spamming dongers and stuff like that but
honestly when you go to a smaller
Channel especially on the creative
section of the website uh where you have
like many painters and digital drawers
and people built robots that the common
sections over there actually really
interesting and sometimes
intellectual so it really just depends
where you
[Music]
go though the majority is probably
yeah
um also I'm a complete idiot hold on a
second I just forgot that this has to go
there I just made a loop around it that
doesn't even go anywhere good job this
exactly what I mean with like destroying
the magic I I I have like ideas but I
don't I'm just a complete and utter nut
job when it comes to trying to even do
anything this is going to be how it's
going to have to be happening and I
don't think I can quite use this
nope so it's just going to have to
connect in a more simple way
[Music]
then I should have not mentioned dongers
damn it guys
why it's all my own fault like trying to
stream on YouTube was already the worst
idea wanting to do a live stream
something special was I think was nice I
like it but
um YouTube
why um I should have taken the first one
then I could have gotten the path covers
to line up with this which it doesn't
quite know it's not the biggest problem
but it it's slightly
annoying um so this is going to be the
exit that's going to like have what a
little rope or not even sure what you
would have over there
[Music]
yeah guys please keep it down on the
dongos that would be amazing thank you
um does anybody know this like what do
you have like the exit of a small little
attraction like this because I'm not too
sure um I could have PLS around this
nice little lights kind of decorate that
fine but realistically speaking I'm not
too sure what I should do with this um
hm
what goes
there I just put a rope over there like
that a person that works at the park and
just kind of close and um hi Mother YOLO
swag by the
[Music]
way well yeah Infinity does bring up a
good point like having a smaller
community on Twitch so people people
kind of get to know each other more
rather than just it being one big chaos
while somebody tries to play Roller
Coaster 3 amongst all that just
stupidity it's something that you know I
was kind of afraid of but I think my
channel is still small enough that's
actually something that I wish for the
future like to keep my channel small
enough so it still stays a bit
personal um I know that sounds weird
but at least I still have the idea that
there's a smaller Community where I like
know all the people that it's I always
feel like roller coaster Gen 3 is this
little Farmers Village on the big
internet and the internet is like the
United States like everybody knows each
other in the village nobody outside the
village knows of the existence of the
village but it's nice inside the village
and as long as I don't get out of the
village it's uh it's all cool that's the
sort of thing that I feel like it is and
that's the sort of thing that I feel
like I want it to
stay that's that rope is going to keep
hordes of women who want to get on the
chair swing and men to I'm sorry um and
that's a bad
[Music]
idea um Peace of prestige is actually
still working on a windmill set so I'm
still sort of I'm not really waiting on
that but um if he does finish that that
would be amazing to use and that's
basically the plan at the moment yeah I
know really depending on somebody else
but it was just so funny since he made
that bridge exactly when I needed it and
then I was like hm I could also use a
windmill over here and he was like I'm
going to build a windmill set that's uh
sort of what's going on there at the
moment which is why I'm not starting on
it yet and honestly I don't think I am
really good enough at it to try it
myself also there aren't any side like
curbs for those other ones so I might
want to not use that one thank
you
I don't think I'll be building a coaster
too
soon I mean sure the intim in the
English area at least it's probably
going to be an
intim I also want to make this thing
like this sort of
color might look a tiny bit better I
think so there's a lot of grayish Brown
going on over here I would like to get
rid of the Grays since it is a theme
park after all so I'm going to try like
this on this side maybe change it on the
other side if it is
successful and hio or LM I can't see if
that is an i or an L that is still like
stupid the entire thing is like the
capital I looking almost identical to
the normal lowercase
[Music]
l
yeah what else do I want to get in
here I'm not sure what I should put over
here like for a thing should I or should
I not get the um what do you call them
that's one thing turntable should I not
get should I or should I not get a
turntable that's basically why I was
trying to say um since it's such a small
ride realistically speaking I might just
want to get one in
but then again no let's just get a
simple rope
in um and then just like pretend there
is a sort of person from the park
standing over there at least that's the
[Music]
idea and better might actually be to get
a cloth
rope I mean I like the cloth more it's
basically how that
is
yeah
and then decorate it with um lights and
Planters and all that good stuff later
on and get pathwork for
it that should
work I can I can go with that still also
need to find out how I can even finish
that
[Music]
part that being said I would also like
to really add some lights to that
[Music]
thing
this is one of my favorite tracks
[Music]
definitely block what idiots um let's
see oh God guys please how do I even
block people on
this
[Music]
um I thought you couldn't sent links on
this thing but um apparently somebody
just sent a link to a porn
site least that's what I
think and I can't moderate it damn
it let me see I'm I'm going to log in
and see how that
works
and in the meantime open up my um
[Music]
lights not quite doing it say the second
set
you can't send links um I'm not sure
somebody said that you can't send links
and somebody else posted link um I am
very confused at the
[Music]
moment and um this definitely won't
become my usual thing no I still like
switch a lot more don't worry about it
[Music]
only problem with these lamps really is
they weird
lighting uh which you don't notice as
much on these ones
but it's still definitely
there might want to try the eing lights
though I think this is the only one with
um oh holy that actually works like
a charm
here we go best
soundtrack um I removed another one of
these are you
[Music]
kidding yeah like the entire how you
manage the chats is a lot better in
twitch too like don't get me wrong I
mean it's cool that YouTube has this
sort of function to stream and it's
still mainly a video streaming service
and twitch just focuses on streams but
it's just God
[Music]
awful all right yeah I think that um
because what I did see was that YouTube
has a sort of blocked list like certain
websites you just can't post in YouTube
live chats and
things like that is basically how it
works but perhaps if you get a shady
enough points sight it does
[Music]
work but yeah I'm going to have to focus
on the uh PK for a ttin a
[Music]
bit
H do think this is the best sort of
thing that I can use for that seems like
it there's still a lot of work to be
done
[Music]
there um I just had a tiny bit of an
idea since this part is looking just a
little bit boring at the moment I could
maybe just add a simple rope fence on
top of
that um which only comes as a rope like
that so that's a bit of a shame it's
going to take a while to make
[Music]
it say something Dutch oh that's a
request that I do get quite
often um I don't know what to really say
and hi Leah by the way it's funny how
people are saying um twitch is the
better Community while I see actually
like half the people that I see in here
I've also seen on Twitch so that's
really cool actually um but say
something dut that's always hard
umon yeah that's how it works um for all
you non-dutch people out there I just
said I like
melons um though honestly um pineapple
is probably better I don't know I'm
always kind
of kind of stuck between those two which
food I like best it's hard to really say
in any case I'm probably digressing a
tiny a
bit what if I did lie about like where I
came from like I said that I was from
Armenia all this time never spoke the
language but just did that because um
that's that's not nice towards the
people who don't speak
Armenian like you could have done that I
think I missed an opportunity
[Music]
there all right good point
well damn
it also this is a bit of a sad
melancholic day because it's the last
day of the summer
vacation um so that's also going on in
my mind at the moment ah you don't work
you definitely
don't damn it why is this song so
good now I feel like the best thing to
go with over here is just get the um
these things I'm not even kidding get
the um Gard topiaries my overused little
things probably use them way too often I
have haven't I just so good actually get
those both in on the corners and
something else in the middle I'd
say
there we
[Music]
go um it's actually a CFR um I only made
the sort of base for this chess Wing
which was a really simple thing really I
don't have the modeling skill whatsoever
to actually make an actual chair swing
I've never tried it but I doubt I can
um in case you're wondering it's from
the aftering Custom Scenery packs um
sort of um it's really hard to find it
though if you look for the eing Custom
Scenery packs or Custom Scenery you
might be able to find it on that page
um don't know exactly what it's called
how does it show up in
game okay not
you please don't um
see I always misclick every single
goddamn thing little chair swing oh
that's just the name that says a
lot oh we still got one more week I
think most people have already started
like last week but
yeah I think in two weeks no one week
everybody's going to start because Labor
Day least that's how it should work in
Washington maybe some other states and
or
countries um but over here it's already
started in most regions except mine
which is going to start
tomorrow I really need to get the uh the
windows in and the door over here so I
can actually uh start finishing this
building
there we go actually uh no there we
go oh you are slightly too too yeah
pretty damn big what what else should I
get in this probably a Better Door but
it's just just a tiny bit I don't know
it's so
narrow I make you that
color
I mean this would be really colorful but
actually sort of like
that not too bad just still not sure
what I should get in for the windows
there or if I can try and find a good
door in these sets so I don't see
anything oh my why is the placement this
window so incredibly
weird I mean I'd go with that
but ideally it would be placed a tiny
bit lower than
[Music]
that and I don't know if there's much
else that I can try Main Street sets
it's the only thing I can really come up
with
and particularly this
one but yeah that's incredibly weird as
well
nope I think it's just going to be the
uh the Dutch windows it's going to have
to be the Dutch windows but a different
door I'm not happy about this door it's
too
[Music]
narrow and then get this one in and also
get the CO shutters for that because
that's the main dra for me really the
shutters they're
everything if I can get the right colors
there seriously though those shutters
just scream the word
Holland okay for everybody body who is
still talking about twitch this is a um
once YouTube stream since it is episode
100 and figured I would do something
special for that but not something that
would like um be focusing on the thing
that I'd be doing in a special way
rather than actually doing something in
roller coaster 3 so like not like um
let's get drunk and try to make some
good stuff in the game or something like
that um because that would ultimately
just result in a terrible Park so I
don't want to still focus on the park
itself and felt like it was the best
hood of idea that was before I realized
again how terrible YouTube streaming
thing is but then again I've complained
about that way too much
already um that's just that's just
negative atmosphere you don't want to
have
that slightly
better uh thing is can I find the actual
door for
it
anyway
and I have no idea what's going on with
that pure account I I suppose that's
another thing that I'm missing it may
have just dropped and just boosted into
something like that um but like on
Twitch you can actually see the viewer
list that also helps quite a
bit um but yeah where are the doors
anyway are the just for curtains I mean
yeah these are these are the doorway
sort of
things um so that should definitely be a
doorway in here
somewhere just can't find it he where's
that thing come
on
um okay that's definitely just chairs
that's definitely just whatever you're
supposed to to even do with those things
I seriously have no idea these railings
are absolutely amazing I've never even
used them I don't know why I definitely
need to do that at some point um I just
yeah there's no door in
here so does this imply you would have
to use the door from the seventh set
since this is the set that comes after
that ah there we go it all makes sense
now never
mind
[Music]
well I don't know why it happened it
just uh happens
sometimes sometimes something is not
what people want to see I suppose I
don't
[Music]
know I always see viewers like wondering
about the view count and if I could give
any advice to anybody don't do that
don't worry about the view count
whenever ever um plus I'm happy to even
have any viewers at any point I mean I
always talk about this but I still
remember the days that I got like one
viewer blackout like every single stream
that I
did those were the
days no I don't think I should put those
in just not too sure about doing it like
this like ideally I would also have
pillars around it I could try
[Music]
that um the stream has been up for about
40 minutes I think right now um also I
don't do song requests on this uh stream
over here you can't that's another thing
that's much better on Twitch like song
requests
everything you'd almost wonder why
YouTube is even trying to start up its
entire live streaming thing but
um like I can't do it because uh some
doesn't really exist and don't want to
exactly leave it for that plus it's a
terrible song that's also an important
thing my version of remember the name oh
my God I could do that I could
definitely do that but I have had not
enough fear for that
[Music]
I don't know if I would do that honestly
maybe at some point I will do the G
drunk and live stream but thing is if I
would ever do such a thing I wouldn't I
wouldn't like embarrass myself on
YouTube I've done it before on Twitch
and I'm all right with
that by the way I'm pretty all right
with these pillars as
well um just not too sure about it but
it does make the building overall look
quite a bit more
interesting just still worried about
these about these
things still look like they could use
some more anything
really who has the worst taste ever and
then
[Music]
what what I have the worst taste in beer
what I don't know for how long I'll be
streaming
um ideally still like two hours or
something um but I might also get tired
of it
honestly there okay so I'll try to focus
on roller Co 3 for a bit
again see that's another thing that I
really I'm like really on the F about
about like streaming in general I like
it and it's fun to do and sometimes even
helps me to get into the game but
sometimes you just spend more time
reading the chat back and rep Ling to
people and stuff then you're actually
focusing on the game itself I do feel
like I'm better at the game whenever I
play it
alone H I do like that one tree over
there though helps break up the
buildings a tiny bit make it seem less
like one big block one big simple facade
basically um I don't know about them
hitting defenses they honestly might
yeah
just don't think I can get it in any
less tight than
that yeah now that you mention it that
is pretty stupidly
close what do I want to do with that
that's a that's actually a good question
since I might want to move it out I'll
um keep that in mind I might want to
move it out 1.5 I mean 0.5 on all sides
that should definitely do it uh because
it is really close at the moment and I
won't dare to lower those fences since
it's a que after
all but yeah that should be all
right only other problem that I do run
into if I do that is that it's also
going to be really close to the
restaurant and that's one
[Music]
thing oh and by um pomas and um hi Dutch
fire hawk by the
way and very good idea I should
definitely save at this
point yeah should I move this thing out
what if I test it see if it does hit it
too badly
oh my God that was actually a lot worse
than I expected I thought it would like
lift up but um forgot that this is
prehistoric
attraction oh you can't just close it
down instantly it just
doesn't damn that's also
stupid ah going to have to let this
thing do its thing and close
it yep I'm definitely going to have to
move that
out very naive to place them that close
actually
didn't think of
that it's not going to be I'm
technically just going to do it in the
same way just moved out half a tile not
entirely sure how much I'm going to like
that and that
no but I have to do it really
[Music]
do yeah so many feet and everything was
getting chopped off
there
um I'm streaming on YouTube at the
moment um because it's episode 100 of
the let's play which was the live
episode um so I'm Live on YouTube at the
moment since the let's play is a YouTube
[Music]
thing H yeah that's how much distance I
have to keep from that thing man I am
really limiting myself
there oh I'm going to have to do it just
not sure how much I'm going to like
that it also looks better in a in a sort
of way
but I don't know how to really work
around this in a good looking way
though oh right those things work like
that almost forgot about
that can I remove you
also why is that wait a second like
every time I use the right Mouse button
it just changes in some Weir
way and hi got Chicago by the way and
coaster
gaming a chair Wing that doesn't have
the carousel theme I'm actually not too
sure I think I have seen chair wings
with different thingses before
but like bats and stuff but I'm not
actually sure what you can get damn it
that one time it does remove it I decide
to double
click yeah that was bound to happen um
question is I'm actually going
to I'm going to kill myself with that
later one but not something to worry
about at some other stage I'm going to
have to work into the thing in a second
here so there we go
going to keep it smaller on this
[Music]
side and that'll be the exit
then yep that's how it will work right
now um actually wait H us
wait no remove you
[Music]
please and high ballistic sign go by the
way um only problem is that I am also
planning to have some sort of buildings
either that's or um foliage on this side
uh but the current plan is to have some
simple buildings though I'm not too sure
about that if I move the que into that
direction I do feel like it's going to
be a lot larger than this plus there's
the fact that the queue itself already
takes in like an entire half rotation
unless I decide to change it and that's
going to make like the side of the
restaurant a tiny bit smaller which I do
want to keep as large as I can but I'll
try to work around actually see uh how
far I can get with
that
okay so if I want to do it like this I'd
like to have
the I like to have that one big curve
basically around here I'd say no that
that's not going to work
um now I'm probably going to have to use
just straighter diagonal pieces for
that kind of like
that except slightly
[Music]
changed yeah now
what it's going to make that's going to
make it a tiny bit harder though to get
that in
right question is can I get this in no
that's probably going to hit
it most likely going to come really
[Music]
close oh that actually
works and I'm not sure about this
but I think this could work
somehow it's just going to be really
hard with the little rope thing so I
can't get that in
now I make that the exits it could
definitely
work but I have no idea how to fit this
in
right um I'm not going to really get in
Mr Bones World
[Music]
ride I'm currently working on HS swing
here um the frame rate isn't the best
but I'm checking it on my laptop and it
is all right for me there though it is
still roller coast 3 and the frame rate
is
still not exactly what you want it to
[Music]
be question is how will I get that rope
in since ideally I would have to like it
like this since that would preserve the
most amount of space and also would look
all right thing is if I test it is is it
going to go through it cuz I think it is
um yep that is way too close the other
ones are good though but that is just
that's not going to happen like this
damn that's a really weird chess Wing by
the way
though so you are not
safe most definitely not can I remove
you though there you go
[Music]
thanks and hi Mr Swift nuts by the
way my school is to my school is
starting tomorrow
and yes Mario Galaxy music is the best
thing um thing is I mean this is um
we're going to have hordes of little
children who want to ride on this ride
so I can't exactly keep it open like it
is at the moment okay uh here's the deal
I'll turn this into a four curve I'm
going to go over this path I can't
really avoid it um but I'm going to have
less on the path and I'm going to still
have room over here for Planters nice
little things uh but it's time to move
on and I think that should work all
[Music]
right um Park file size as in um the F
yeah file size it's around 10 megabytes
it isn't an exact maximum but there is
no exact maximum like
I think theoretically your par can be as
large as you want it to be but after 10
megabytes it really starts lagging and
it also starts randomly crashing it just
starts having issues after 10 megabytes
and that's the sort of Mech that people
would like to go for but I have to add
that this park at this point is between
12 and 13 megabytes it's pretty bad and
it tends to crash so I really have to
save quite often that being said I
haven't done too much at this point so
I'm not too worried about this but I
should soon save
[Music]
again okay so that's how it's going to
go
down feel like this should be all right
actually I'm placing that thing in the
wrong
place and then have the PLS around that
[Music]
basically oh no not that song
part clean up always yep but as soon as
you save it reverts it back to its old
file size so it is only like a very
temporary remedy to the problem Lodge
Edis away that's why it's
at still can't save you from Roller
Coaster Tycoon 3's terrible terribleness
but it's all
[Music]
right they can at least keep it up until
some point in
time why why thank you there we
go thought this was FTC this is FTC
placement H QTC over
there actually that looks more like a
um stdc is for sure not but Etc could
fit in there I think yeah there we go
perfect slightly going through it but I
don't want this pot to stick out too
much
there and I feel pretty happy about that
I'm going to have trees and stuff over
here and of course lights and more
things yes Mario Galaxy music is
amazing I'm sorry we don't do song
requests on Youtube it'll be back soon
though
H it's just too much of a hustle I can't
really do that since I would have to
like on my computer over here and I
don't have any other screen go to these
songs directly and um that wouldn't be
too good of a
thing speaking of not being too good of
a thing these spatters don't really work
out
there ideally I would like to have some
more height in
here um thing is I think I haven't I
don't think I have I actually have but
still these nope weird
placement do these ones work these
actually do
work and sort of a different one in the
middle I'd
say okay this song does not
fit it has Reverb at least for some sort
of Spacey feel
[Music]
oh and yep if you go to my about section
you will be able to find my style
themed oh and thanks
B um in any case I think that should do
for that it's still looking very empty I
know definitely want to get some other
things in underneath this thing but I
want to sort of procrastinate that until
some point in time that I feel confident
enough to do
it and what the rest of this little
section is all about I'm not even sure I
think I'll do the same sort of water
front thing as I've done this side maybe
not with The Birches different trees but
a similar sort of
idea though I would like to keep it a
tiny bit more open since this is the
more rural side of the entire part of
this park and I don't want to spoil this
view honestly can't spoil this view of
the facad
day the pack gameplay I was pretty happy
to see that yeah um I must say that I'm
pretty much though carefully on the hype
train again I'm really looking forward
to the release now though there are
still many things that I'm worried about
it's really hard since like at this
point the the community is really Dei it
this like I feel like half of the people
are still very cynical and the other
half is hyping way too much um but at
least I feel like Roller Coaster Tycoon
world has a very good potential to
actually be a worthy successor and
probably better than roller Co second 3
and as long as that's true I'm confident
that it's going to be
[Music]
good
now about these trees though I mean I'm
pretty sure that since this has the vti
placement as well I should be able to
get spices trees in here just not sure
what sort of tree would actually work
there wondering can I get the poet in
for that oh whoops I
can't still getting the poet in would be
pretty nice it's a very light lush green
tree um so always helps to break up sort
of greyness
there just not sure about
that
like if I get another one in there it's
going to be way too many trees I think
around this area I'll get some much much
smaller sort of things like these
benches in on this side and just keep it
at that
basically my favorite Coast is most
definitely twist
[Music]
streaks
that's all
[Music]
right and I think I will just get these
same benches in now one thing that I do
need to think about is what okay so we
have one QTC and one
FTC sure made things complicated for
myself there um colors are just this
brown I think yep that should be good to
go it's one FTC and one QTC is all I
really need to
REM why the game does that I have no
idea but it's pretty damn
annoying there we
go actually I like to move
that not sure what the placements are on
the other side actually no it's the same
on the other side
just going to place these benches in the
same sort of
layout that should do that um now I
don't think I can get a tree up in here
but maybe a little store that would sell
ice cream or something like that would
be
good think I'd like to try
that and different Planters since I've
already used those Planters on that
side
I think that was just a short
track this song really reminds me of you
Nikki or at least the loop in the
background
do one want to try
these uh okay that's EDC never
mind H looks all right
but okay I've already used those over
there never mind I cannot do
[Music]
that it's going to have to be not
those suppose these actually like
[Music]
that there are many flowers oh wait I've
already used those on that side there's
too many pots over here way too many
flowers in the Dutch area
overall starting to even lose track of
what I've already placed and what I
haven't placed
yet is there anything else that I can
get in here anything that I haven't
placed
yet I don't think I've used these
yet except they are way too large H it's
almost like a flower bad in a
sense and I'm not sure how this would
look sure I took the ETC
right
H oh
whatever yeah there we go that one just
has a weird placement for some
[Music]
reason I am all right with that but it's
it's not the best thing
really and um my ERS sleep
tight I don't think I'll be getting in
Belgium I'm sorry Belgian people but um
I don't really have enough room for
other countries in
here besides I've already laid out my
areas at this point and there's not
really any space left for
Belgium oh you look pretty good
actually should I go with
that I think I will um granted I still
need to find something for this little
spot over right
here just
wondering have I tried the apple tree
yet with this alt placement that's one
thing but it could work over
here
um question is where do I want
it
[Music]
do I want it's over
there or do I want it here I'm not
sure um I think I actually want it here
that's going to break the Symmetry but
um it wasn't too symmetrical to begin
with just looks slightly better over
[Music]
here
I know I was thinking that I I can still
get a ice cream thing over
there and if I got one thing from
Belgium though like you said just a
fries snack shop or just some waffles
Place could try to get that in but I'm
really limited when it comes to the
space
there but that being said the only real
planning that I have for next to the
windmill is going to be a little kids
playground and um other than that
there's not much yet
there so I may be able to get something
in that's actually large enough I'd say
need to get that little ice cream thing
in I'd
say and yes this tree is going to
complete my park with the with the
building of this one tree my Park is now
truly
finished but I will get a dark ride in
by the way that something that I am
planning for the English area at the
moment so this is the okay that was
actually the hot dog St never mind
here's the beautiful ice cream little
thing inama jig I know it's not
typically Dutch but um it's I think it
is a bicycle that is my way of getting a
bicycle in here so that's one thing oh
it's going to be the only bicycle though
that's a shame like it's it's not no
it's not a Dutch sort of area where you
don't have bicycles being spammed
everywhere which is the only sort of
Shame just not too happy about this
thing's placement slightly better place
like
that um can I remove you
though
and it's not facing the uh this part of
the park anymore but it's not too big of
a problem as long as I get that sexy
little scoop sign
in beautiful scoops of
[Music]
ice
magnificent um no we're all right I'd
[Music]
say yep there you go
uh whatever else I had oh yeah right
these little things I'm not even sure
where were they
in going to have to find
that I think it was the AFC
[Music]
set there we
go these things are pretty
[Music]
cute
very cute I might want to
[Music]
add little uh little baskets
basically oh that's also a good idea
people are mentioning the um like
different Dutch foods that I could have
in it
which is actually a good idea as
well the real problem just with that
like getting some of those Dutch food
stores is that they don't exist and I
don't think I really have the modeling
skills to get them in
[Music]
either but yeah getting it in like this
should pretty much shape us shape up
this area in a good way I think I can
the uh the roof in for this building
think there's anything I still need to
add wait one thing might want to still
add some lights around the entrance of
that
door and call it a day for that
[Music]
then Dam it why are you so either way
too low or either way too
[Music]
high and if I do it like that that's not
going to be a very fitting lamp right
there
nope not a very good idea I'll try the
Alpine lamp on that
actually if I still know where that
thing
is I think it's in the uh fifth
set yep there we
go and she a thing of
beauty uh with the wrong placement there
there we
go it doesn't stick out enough though
that's the big issue there
[Music]
Don you're an absolute genius I don't
know if you were there but at some point
I noticed the cheese in Alpine Village
and said I have to use that later just
remembered but I completely forgot about
that that is such an amazing thank you I
owe you my life I think um I definitely
need to get that cheese
in
um but first also I I would like to mess
around with that vodin Cafe set I've
never even used it but it's a pretty
good set so I'm not sure why I haven't
used it yet um but in any case
I only thing is these are slightly too
high
prob and I just done goofed on that okay
I'm going to get the a war in and just
get Alpine Village five lamps and just
get the cheese right away while I'm edit
uh but first I need to repair the damage
let's
see I think that was war one yep there
we go oh whoops not like
[Music]
that streaming for 1 hour and 17 minutes
you should stop wait a second why is
that no we don't you you won't get rid
of me that
easily
[Music]
yeah that's actually the best thing not
entirely happy about it but no other
lamps really work too well there um now
wonder was the cheese
again um but because thing is this is a
cheese plate this is the thing that I
was indeed thinking about as well
um oh when you're doing the restaurant I
don't know about doing the Interiors
though that's the big thing I will have
to do some Interiors later on but it's
definitely a building for which I won't
be doing Interiors at this
point um there's one other thing though
and I'm not entirely sure what village
set it wasn't I think it was the first
one which has a little outside cheese
thing I find it yes yes yes
where come on
I think I'm done way too much there
we go a sign with cheese on it I mean
I'm definitely going to have that in the
Dutch area I can't not have it the only
problem with this thing is it's got like
the most stupid placement ever but um
actually works over
there just not too happy about the call
of the cheese over
there if you make it like that it's
going to be
it's going to be pretty weird as
well maybe I should hang it outside one
of these buildings but these aren't
restaurants so that's not going to make
any sense
whatsoever
H outside over here
somewhere
maybe I mean souvenir shop could have
[Music]
them I'm not sure about
that that is a legit Pac-Man yeah it's
just 100% Pac-Man yep and it's
got the same color too which is the
problem because cheese doesn't really
have that color color isn't really this
color and it isn't this color either
it's a bit of an in between
thing why does this music remind me of A
Clockwork Orange this really sounds like
the o to Joy rendition in A Clockwork
Orange is that just me I don't
know and by the way that is exactly how
I feel about um the reals mod um you
mean this rail over
here it I'm not sure what his name was
anymore but I can look that up in a bit
here trolly track if this is the one
that you mean
um let's see you there we go this thing
actually has a credits thing with it
trolly Track by yeah that guy J mayz
with is
at um my favorite rcd game is the first
one after that roller coaster G 3 after
that roller coaster e to um the rest
doesn't
exist okay looking at it now I'm I'm
just going to get this cheese in
Yolo could always move it but I just
have to remember that the cheese is
there I just I can't notot have that
little cheese sign in the Dutch area
just it just has to
happen so there we go that's cheese now
could even get some hanging baskets in
only problem is these things are way too
low to really get them in properly so I
don't think that's going to quite work
that being said I can definitely still
get a little bit of a base wall over
here
[Music]
in oh for the train station um that is
actually does mz's train
CT not sure what it's called in game I
think it's what is that
bugger those mz's real R that's the name
of that
thing yep I am still definitely
interested in Roller Coaster Tycoon
World um especially seeing last night's
stream footage that was pretty good
still definitely some problems with it
but it's not a complete f Kure at least
that's already a big
feat like uneven said it doesn't destroy
atari's
Legacy at
[Music]
least yeah what if I did what if I did
build like an arcade Hall and got that
same cheese sign outside there like
would people notice like if they didn't
that would be the funniest thing ever
like just have the cheese sign and the
arcade Pacman sign be the exact same
thing
and human psychology would make it
impossible to notice it without
knowing in any case I feel pretty safe
happy everything good about the way this
looks now so I think it's time to bring
in the tables this this is just going to
be a really small simple suit restaurant
I do want to get the tables
in and also High stret L audio is desync
from video is it
really I don't think it is but if it is
then uh that's another reason to hate
YouTube and go back to Twitch forever
also
hi this is uh this complete
what was I going to do I I just
forgot it already okay there we go I
know
[Music]
it I can find it there we go the cafe
kit and don't I I think this just has
the bars and stuffff uh yep it does
H wow you can actually build buffets
with this it's pretty
awesome um but there should I thought
there was also a wall section of that
cuz where else are the like tables and
the things going to
be I'm not
sure um because I can't find it in here
either
okay let's open that again okay that was
just
the
no that's buffet bar and Deli and
there's extras but that's about it isn't
there anything else in here okay hold on
a
second Atari style
themed and changed on that's Cafe kit
table sets where do I find these table
sets
that's the big question I suppose
[Music]
here I turn on all the
themes not sure if this is going to even
work
out yeah you've got to realize that like
most of the people who did see it at
pack were just casual players and and
the delay is strong strong too but
that's on twitch too I can't complain
about that but most casual plays like
the average roller Co tacken 3 coaster
doesn't look entirely realistic either
not everybody knows about the existence
of B&M and all that stuff and how it
works so I honestly can't blame people
um for that only thing
is I wish there was somebody in the
right mind who actually made a straight
lift Hill because I have yet to see a
straight LIF Hill and it is quite
upsetting
[Music]
weed I'll get i'll get all three of them
actually I don't know about the uh the
clogs it's going to be really hard to
get in um but yeah P of prestige is
currently working on a lift on a a
windmill why is
he why do I just not find
those I am an idiot I've been searching
in the wrong place
probably um but yeah P of prestige is
working on a windmill so if he get if he
finish that finishes that I am going to
have that in the park so that's how
that's going to
happen oh these just
come made complet but
why why do I have to have paths for them
damn it V these are amazing so why are
they like path
things some of the things he did just
mindboggling brilliant and stupid at the
same
time so we go
here
and actually just get the normal uh sort
of chairs and
stuff can't even place any of this
what oh
god well never mind then it's just going
to be the uh the coffee shop
chairs
which I can't even get oh okay that
makes a lot of sense actually I can get
only get them in on the sides of
paths well it's over not going to use
that
[Music]
set the um path divider SL curb over
here is um from Brian
CH Borders or branches 94
borders
um
stics does he have a furniture set I
don't even know of that I do know that
he has some sets
um and I thought I had some as well
thing is there is the um yeah these
furniture sets that the
one oh it has a full tile placement and
that's too big problem it's not very
versatile it's an all right set but it
doesn't really work too
well which is generally why I don't
really use it too often actually do
forget about these things they don't
really look too good it's actually a
good planter here and this is a
surprisingly good little awning as well
it's a shame that it's all like full
tile
placement um so yeah I was basically
thinking at this point the Main Street
and or Alpine Village sets are my best
bet I
think not sure what else I could even
try but these ones are pretty
good let's get some simple ones of these
in and then I think it should be
fine I think that's
fine just want to recolor them not even
sure it's sort of yeah yellow wood
that's not going to make
it
Super Mario Maker what is Super Mario
maker I do have I've had Super Mario
Builder for years uh which is really fun
but I've never heard of Super Mario
maker is that actually a game in which
you can design your own Mario
games because if so I need that in my
life oh what sort of offset placement do
we have okay they don't change when you
rotate actually this one
does so this would be the best placement
for that I'm going to make this way too
complicated for myself but uh oh well I
always to get the tables in like
[Music]
that so I think that's how it's going to
work that should be all right I'm just
really worried about the AA placements
and their chairs and how that's going to
work SL probably not going to work oh
the sequel of Mario
Paint oh that's pretty cool
[Music]
actually um the borders were um Brian
ch's
concrete borders
[Music]
yep and I do really like the gardening
chairs it's just that they are not
really your sort of restaurant chairs I
do use them for them sometimes but for
this particular thing with the more
darker colors and much more thick look
to it that I wanted I feel like these uh
tables which just be a tiny bit better
here only real downside to them is that
they're a lot less easy to use and just
are a complete pain in the dick
with all their offset placements I hate
you oh
well um that
works take offset one a I think yep
there we
go oh oops this is not the right
table
and then we go back to one
B
yep I think that's
good I'm not the only thing is you can't
even get to the other side from here
there's like if there's people sitting
and they take and they just take yeah I
might want to get rid of that
actually just have five tables outside
it's not a it's not a lot but um it's
better than just completely blocking the
road over
here it's going to be hard to enter the
restaurant
otherwise other side is still fine
though shouldn't really worry about that
but these are some bad developments
right
here and Y but straight banana said if
you go to alienware's Twitch Channel
though it is it has also been uploaded
on YouTube but I don't really know how
to find it I found it but it's like a
really barely even viewed video and I
don't know what the title
is um a review well the demo didn't
really come out there was only footage
about the demo and I don't know I'm not
really the spokesperson of roller
coaster Ty world I don't think I'll make
a video about
that like that the whole thing of making
update videos of whatever is really
happening I could do that but it's not
really my main sort of
[Music]
thing what I will definitely try to do
is pick it up as soon as I can and play
it as soon as I can and make video
videos of it as soon as I can if I have
the time for it at that
point wait I think I forgot which one I
took offset two I think yep there we
go I think that's all
right there we
go
tiny bit of a restaurant
there um pathworks is just a tiny bit
boring in this area overall but oh well
there not too much I can do about that
not sure what I can end this with if I
just want to get a dead end over
here
um yeah the exit is like over here exits
and entrance little thing at the moment
probably Place
holders but yeah that will be that I
need to get a door in this building most
definitely
do just not sure what sort of door would
even fit very
well I mean this one's really really
big
wait a
second okay double doors is there a
single version of this
door I don't think there is this PL is
pretty cool
though except I don't have any quarter
tile trees or anything
but it could have been useful if I
did
wait see through the
window which window
actually because not something that I
was really worried about like having the
um Alpha Windows where you would see
through them and see
bricks um but as far as I know I checked
and you can't see what's like you can't
see the brick walls behind the windows
anywhere or at least that's what I
thought um though if you do see that
going on anyway don't hesitate to say
because um not really a big fan of that
happening
either at the moment I definitely think
that Roller Coaster Tycoon world has
more of the hype it's actually going to
be pretty big a competition I think um
since you know we've seen much much more
of roller coaster in world at this point
and Planet Coast is just a simple
trailer not much else really um then
again overall I did put my trust more
into Frontier than in Atari or whatever
they're working
with just because of their
history and like how Frontier has
handled Elite with all their um updates
and and death Vlogs and responding to um
the community and what they wanted I was
really confident that Frontier would
pull off well but now that Atari seems
to be going on the right path as well I
know was really hard to say I'm still
leaning towards Park attacks
actually and this door is all right just
like it's not really realistic and a
tiny bit too large
maybe especially if you compare it to
the door next to it I mean that's
essentially the uh the immersion
breaking thing
there get the side version
in plus it's not too fancy of a
door I just don't think that CTR sin
sets don't have any doors in it I
think oh wait they do but way too large
in any
case can't exactly use
that
and that window is just too damn similar
to the one over there two them pretty
much exactly the
same and hi
Nick oh about your windows oh never mind
oh you're actually sharing your own
house that might not be the best idea
ever uh I'm from Holland by the
way so um same here
because Mario because I like Mario
Galaxy a lot and because YouTube
absolutely sucks and can't play or at
least will ruin your day once you play
anything
[Music]
copyrighted uh now given Mario Galaxy is
copyrighted but I'm less likely to be to
get a strike over
[Music]
this I could even get a planter box in
here somewhere just that window doesn't
really work out there see this is i
that's not even a door I wouldn't even
call that a door oh God this was the
door in this
set it just um just doesn't work out too
much so yeah what sort of window do I
just want to go with do I go with this
one I don't think so that's doesn't seem
like too good of an
idea I think I'm going to just try the
window from the other sets even though
it's going to be the same window these
are essentially the same building just
with different materials anyway it's not
going to be the worst thing to ever
happen to my
park and get a little flower box in for
that thing somehow that would be pretty
[Music]
good Mario Kart 8 soundtrack I've
actually never heard
that oh wait
good thing this is Nintendo music
you do get problems for that that is
actually that actually a pretty likely
thing um I think I did forget about
that oh well we'll see what happens I
mean this is one video if I don't get
like any uh I'll be glad to just
keep the video up to just keep my
channel um I mean I technically can't
even be taken down for this but um yeah
hope hopefully won't
[Applause]
happen I don't even know why Nintendo is
like being so stuck about stuck up about
any YouTuber doing anything with their
[Music]
content they're essentially hurting
themselves with
[Music]
that
yeah you need three strikes to be taken
down and though I know of like Nintendo
problems I don't know of Getting striked
By Nintendo for music um plus I have
actually used Mario Galaxy music on like
two of my videos before which I didn't
have any problems with so hopefully I
should be all
right or hopefully I will be all
right still good of music though and
thing
is I might get in trouble for playing
Nintendo music but I will definitely get
in trouble for playing
[Music]
Muse looks all
right just I don't know it just feels
not entirely
necessary like even though it is empty
like it is right now I feel like it
could still work uh plus I forgot one
thing uh since this is that sort of
building I think I can get it
in think I can get the um top part
in I mean you need this on every single
Dutch building
anyway so there we
go it's there
now I could really really use some
flowers around these things
[Music]
though yeah YouTube is not what it used
to be anymore and um thanks for the
greets from the Netherlands by the way
uh send the greets back to the
Netherlands from the
Netherlands um I kind of remember where
every object is I don't I definitely
don't know that for every single object
or every single set that I have um but
the most commonly used objects that I've
used quite a bit
[Music]
Yeah it it would be very scary if I knew
them
[Music]
all I would probably definitely have a
tiny bit too much of experience in this
game at that
point
actually what if I just get one of them
in keep the rest just
empty doesn't even look that bad okay a
little pot for you and see what you look
[Music]
like question is what po can I even use
here have I used the this one I don't
think I have
really I probably did actually didn't
not on this area so there we
go then I still have this which
is a bit of a problem I need to figure
out how I can end this path in a nice
looking way and not completely ruin
everything in
existence and what movie boys just set
that's my
name
build a roller coaster never ever I am
not known for building roller coasters
pretty much known for building buildings
I will definitely get into roller
coasters soon again too though um next
roller coaster in this park is going to
be in the English area which is the next
area that I'll work on
and it's one of the the first things
that I would like to work on in that
case since it is going to be quite
important in uh how I work around the
layouts and such um but aside from this
I am still working on roller coasters a
s projects I've actually been making
music for protos a Sci-Fi Coast to that
I would like to round up at some point
pretty soon
actually that would be amazing in any
case I really need to like finish this
area over
here just still not sure what I can how
I can do
that okay here's the question which is
probably going to be the worst thing
ever save for a tiny
bit and yeah I did see that live stream
that was
amazing um well amazing is well that
would probably hype it up a tiny bit too
much but um that was really
cool please don't okay thank you please
don't thank you all right so no problems
there yet
and um yeah I'll just end that with a
little appear sort of thing well not
appear since I only have that on the
other side but a little like that little
just going somewhere with this path
basically I think that's the best sort
of thing to end
this
one sentence in Dutch I've actually done
it in the Stream before uh yeah it is
okay I'm going to have to say it anyway
um I don't know I've tried to come up
with many sentences uh give me a
sentence I need to say I
suppose it's really hard to come up with
anything original and um suppose now you
have the chance to come up with
something stupid that I would
say
[Music]
should be a round version there we go
except that's not the round thing I was
looking for a damn it pets sets are the
worst thing okay there we go
this should be it there we
go Hallelujah we got
it I had a job until last
Friday um which was just a uh summer
vacation thing
um well really I was mman but um I don't
have enough time for that anymore in uni
so um just going to focus that and drop
the job and that's how that happened so
not anymore I'm now officially
jobless okay who got
it and
uh oh you missed me because I wasn't
streaming on Twitch I am sorry to hear
about that um I'll get back to you after
the stream don't worry about
it by the way I just uh said I missed
you in Dutch for those of you who don't
understand pck
Latin and um I am on Twitch since this
is officially episode is this was
supposed to actually be a good thing
this was supposed to actually be a
controlled um quiet me trying to focus
on roller coaster 2 3 actually getting
things done but I think I was pretty
naive thinking this would actually work
out stream on
YouTube as Let's Play episode 100 to
celebrate the fact that I have
officially made 100 videos of a boring
game is Quite a
feat you didn't hear the holy you
saw that video you saw that last video
yes you guys saw that last video that
last video by um the Belgian YouTube
poop Creator was absolutely
amazing I mean all his videos are
amazing but the last one was especially
good question is what the did I use
for that Bard dud what the serious I
don't even recognize that one
bit
um yeah I am
pretty why did I use a set I don't even
recognize it must be this one right it
can't not be oh there we go I'm going at
least found it now do you have ho
Corners that would
be I don't think it
[Music]
does well then I'll just get the full
thing in
there I'm going to have to
never mind never mind just just don't uh
going have to see a different way to
sort of finish that up damn how do I do
that um better yet I don't do it like
this uh just take
that remove these and get different path
covers for that section y that's how
it's going to
[Music]
be
uh my favorite theme park in real life
is the fing um also guys in the chats
please keep it English thank you very
much the music never fits with the way
I'm talking the only the only times the
music ever fits in my streams is when
I'm singing along to it and then people
leave the stream because it sounds
terrible doesn't
matter man I'm really missing views and
radio head on my streams that alone just
I need
it I thing is what does fit with roller
coaster tyon 3 I suppose classical music
but I'm not going to bring up my modart
playlist for the
[Music]
stream or Boven oh
Bliss um yeah I do watch Studio
Masa
[Music]
uh the question is what set did I take
that thing
from was it jungle things or was it
pirate things or was it something
else
um well at least pirate things doesn't
seem to have it
there I think jungle okay definitely not
jungle
things um Vikings I'm going to have to
try
Vikings
yeah it must be Vikings it can't not be
there we
go not sure how I'm going to end this
but I will end this somehow and get a
different sort of thing over
[Music]
here uh but then I would have to like
close roller coaster teken 3 and find
wherever that was and somehow play it
and open like Windows media players
separately because it's doesn't
automatically open it in like playlist
mode and it's stupidly complicated or or
I am stupid either one of
those uh probably the
letter oh that's some more gray there's
there's enough gray in this area as is
definitely want to try some other colors
in
there just not sure about this red could
be a tiny bit too I don't know
I'll actually go with
that quite like
it and then got a I would
say sort of thing should I get
there straight to diagonal
[Music]
maybe my favorite
YouTubers
um You probably don't know them Fufu 2
who's like a really underground YouTube
um Pokemon guy person he has like 9,000
subs and he uploads um videos of Wi-Fi
battles and stuff and it's pretty fun
I'm into that kind of
stuff um who else is cool Mike Jens
who's also really unknown he makes video
he's like an English person who reviews
anything shitty that capitalism tries to
force unto the the people um like tell
sell things and it's really
amazing um you could ask us a stupid
question I'm not sure about that what uh
what else do I watch I used to watch a
lot of Jack films but I don't really
anymore but sure did back in the day
there's not many other well I watch
extreme rides I don't know if you know
him but it's a it's a Dutch theme park
sort of person also I realized that I
totally played that cve on the on part
of the park
there should probably do a different
sort of thing
here do it more like that I would
say and see how that
works though it doesn't work too well
damn it yeah the other plan was actually
probably better uh let's go back to
that um the sidewalk edges these
sidewalk edges are from shag guys World
H what am I saying shy guys M Street 5
um yep that's it and these things that
I'm currently using if that was the
thing that you meant is from Moby's
curved walls
yep the frame rate is actually all right
for me I don't really watch John Tron
now I've watched a couple of his videos
but not really in that into that sort of
thing too much but then again I'm not a
a gamer person and I certainly don't
hate John R he's all
right I have probably watched more of
strat's JonTron remixes than JonTron
himself it's very
sad question is how do I even make this
work could also just end it in a sort of
more Sharp Way and see how that works
yeah since real path real pathworks do
have curves but always have like
carefully placed and selected curves
don't have curves
everywhere and you're
welcome and um I don't really watch John
Tron too often but I am familiar with
all the jokes and
everything
[Music]
and yep I have seen the demo of um
Roller Coaster
World I have found all of my Custom
Scenery and um cfrs ctrs all that good
stuff on Custom Scenery
depot.com if you haven't yet you should
definitely check it out it's got pretty
much everything that is in existence
basically uh it's got a good site layout
too and I don't think there's any other
sort of website that I download my stuff
from um actually that's a pretty good
Segway into that sort of thing I still
see many people downloading things from
size like ICT go or just wherever on the
internet but I would really recommend
just get all your stuff from Custom
Scenery Depot it's not just an easy and
good place to find things but it's also
reliable and um ICT go tends to upload
either you know wrong files or upload a
Custom Scenery set pretty much all the
time without the permission of the
author or without even the author
knowing like somebody uploaded MOS some
scenery sets somehow on RCT go and
things like
[Music]
that um I'm 18 years old and I don't
watch too much of Dutch television no
not really too big of a fan if I do
watch television honestly I usually
switch to um Discovery or National
[Music]
Geographic though as a series I like
NCIS and this music I like this music
too but that was off
topic I might want to actually not curve
that
around just turn this into a little
sticking out thing with God and stuff on
it I think that would
work little
fence nice looking lamps gardening
definitely going to
work I like Super Mario Galaxy music and
it hopefully won't get me into copyright
problems I'm very tempted to play radio
head but that's going to have me
killed uh my favorite fan has got to be
um pretty much all the Phillips fans I'm
a really big fan of the uh fans of of
Phillips um very reliable um good
rotation speed and they don't use too
much electricity
[Music]
either and yeah ideally I would have
little boats settle over here that would
be absolutely amazing and even have
boats inside of all this only problem is
can't really find any good boats
anywhere I'll do a hunt for that but
I've already done quite a bit of boat
hunting really and try to download some
sets but can't really get any boats that
look even remotely like the boats that
you would usually find in the
Netherlands and that's a bit of the uh
the big let down when it comes to
that o I'm definitely going to have to
have some sort of edge over
here Mario Galaxy music is all fine in D
until you get to like the themed music
such as this like Egyptian music playing
while I'm trying to build Holland over
here just just doesn't
work a fan not a van that's what I said
a
fan what sort of curve is that even I
think I have no
idea
ouch yep actually know that should just
be a one just a normal one curve yep
there we
go
[Music]
use the pirate
set I don't know about a French um
section like it's tell me that I haven't
really planned and it's going to be
really hard to fit in all the countries
I honestly can't fit in all the
countries within one Park you're going
to have to rule out some things and
since I figured French wasn't really too
special not not really special but um
too much of a unique theme I felt like
it was something that I could leave
out um it's mostly scenery it's mostly a
very small transition sort of area which
also functions as the train station
Place uh but also as a main transition
towards the English area so you don't
have that very abrupt transition from
Spain to England which wouldn't really
work um but I think this would work all
right with the bridge uh forming the
sort of sort of little transition
between those two areas I think it's all
right the Pirates at that is a good
point I think that was where I found one
of those swallow
boats I'm really not
sure
um definitely not an object and
definitely not a spooky theme either do
I don't know why I always confuse spooky
theme with the Adventure
theme um
ither saw roofs it was an objects I
think yeah because this is where all the
other things were yeah
definitely thank you so much actually
holy I just completely forgot that
these boats were
here
um it's nice to have a boat with a
random
rotation oh that's actually a good
rotation it's going to be hard to find
any good
yes yes thank
you uh boat two is probably my favorite
out of the two I mean it's not much but
it's better than nothing I suppose but
their placement is also a bit of a pain
really since you can't exactly put them
next to the water as you would like to
have them in Holland but there's always
that tiny bit of a
difference
um really hope hoping that I could nail
these to the walls using
ropes and hi DJ technoid by the
way I don't like roller coasters in real
life whatsoever I'm the complete biggest
you'll ever
find um and bye movie Boys by the
[Music]
way yeah that is too spooky for
me I'm definitely that scar cow person I
haven't even been to a theme park in
years I don't even know what it's like
to be on a roller coaster to be
honest like I haven't been in a theme
park in many many
years U how do you start building roller
coaster three par with your first TSO um
it's really just a sort of thing that
happened I must admit by the way I was
really really bad in the
beginning
um and the biggest tip that I can really
give is or the most important thing is
to enjoy it but that's probably a big
cliche that anybody will tell you um
actually I took the wrong boat
there uh one thing that you wouldn't
really expect would be too good of an
idea but really does work is just copy
try to copy off other people don't
hesitate to be not unique in the
beginning just see whatever other people
are doing and just blatantly steal
whatever they are doing because it's a
really good way to learn how things are
done like I could just completely copy
one of leontis castles which would make
me like a complete toad for copying his
castles but at the very least I can sort
of get to know how he works uh what sort
of objects he uses for certain things
how he gets his details in and things
like
[Music]
that what's boat hunter that just
reminded me of boat and honor for some
reason and hi magic Turtle Studios by
the
way
boxes and that's actually boxes and
crates I don't know if you can but if
you can but that's probably impossible
plus these things are really really
large and probably don't have the same
sort of
placements you can almost do it but it's
just too large can't get it
in hell I just said it I just
said it I just said it's too large I
can't get it in never mind uh that was
not my
intention um I think I want to see if I
can like rope these to the walls because
that would be the best thing maybe even
get some little walkways down to these
[Music]
things cuz that would be great
too I'm going to see if station gy SC or
something for that Nets wait a second
yeah I did install COA Nets that I've
never even used before I should check
those out see what they're all
about um I use FRS to record um all of
my normal videos but when I do like the
um coaster povs I do record with the
in-game
recorder um because fraps does lag a
tiny bit uh it's not really great for
your coaster povs but um when I'm
playing the game itself um the in-game
recorder has a lot of lag while it's
recording it's not in the videos that
it's that it creates but it does have a
lot of lag while I was recording um so I
would not want to have that while I'm
trying to record my let's
play I can't find station gym
scaffolding at the moment is it just
called
scaffolding cuz I didn't think it was uh
definitely is not H in objects maybe
probably and I think it was in over here
in any
case okay never mind these nuts are
nothing they're really good though
H and I use Sony figas to speed up the
time
lapses oh but damn scaffolding is not
here either where is scaffolding I was
it
called pretty sure it's just station gym
scaffolding
let me try that
again a there we go I found that
and this could maybe be a good
sort of catwalk down to these little
things I'm not too sure about
it
um definitely going
to not get 2 H let's get noral 1
h
let's get that in like that actually no
[Music]
oops okay where do I get the fense where
I want it to
be and why can I not get it where I want
it to
[Music]
be I mean that's how I want the steps
but
uh oh bugger forget about it um I'll get
to that later when I really feel like it
first I need to get some ropes in see if
I can even connect these boats to
[Music]
anything thought that oh no Adventure
theme there we
go and hi a by the
way um I only use OBS for the stream
itself but I never really use it to
record
how did you call that the stream was
almost over I don't know how almost over
it is but yeah I am uh stopping in a
[Music]
bit but yeah I'm not really doing Disney
themes since I'm more into creating my
own stuff rather than making any
Recreations or anything inspired by
anything else also this doesn't connects
uh so that's why I never really do
Recreations of parks of coasters or
anything like
that H there must be some some rope with
a different placement I was hoping but
apparently there
isn't and I can't hit the middle of the
boats
I don't know for sure how long I'll be
going uh not much of an idea
[Music]
really um Pro edits or Pro I I think I
don't know what Pro edit is so I think I
just have Pro edit uh
Pro it's just called Sun Vegas
[Music]
Pro um of course the version that I
acquired in mysterial ways
[Music]
mysterial I didn't just say that I never
said that that never
happened uh another question
is can I get these things in CU that's
basically what you would have you would
have like
those little ports thing my
jigs e no don't do that
like at the entrance of a port like
always have these things and they always
have those white
tops and I was hoping to maybe get those
in and way too here I think that could
work it definitely
does all right I'm going with that
anyway I'll find I'll try to find out
however I can even connect those boats
but I feel all right about it at the
moment and um I'd like to get finish
this fence and do something about this
area oh the soundtrack is over in 15
minutes and hi Roy by the
way yes that is exactly that is exactly
what I was thinking of I had mysterious
ways in my head I'm not even kidding
YouTube mysterial ways
confirmed that is that is beautiful that
is the best thing
ever I'm pretty sure that I put the um
only thing is you probably weren't right
about the soundtrack because I put it on
one I put it on shuffle
and on
[Music]
repeats um I don't think it's on repeat
but like some versions of the songs and
hi mat Wix or however it's pronounced uh
hi in any case um I think there are like
different versions of many of the songs
like um there are three versions of the
the what's it called The Observatory
theme and stuff so that's how you how
you kind of get
that question is what sort of FS do I
even want to have over
[Music]
here what would be nice I haven't really
used the farm fence and you can
definitely use this on like not Farm
places basically I'm just not sure if it
would work over here I think it
would yeah I'm not I don't think that's
too
[Music]
bad I can get it raised
there and um I'll get some simple Rock
work
flowers um an abundance of foliage in
over here and one of the things that I
really need to get is a large tree right
here and that should block the view of
all this shitty right
there and hi
[Music]
Olaf I have actually made a bar 1898 is
coaster in the um short Leaf Lake Park
um but I don't know if I'll really be
doing that again I mean of done that
sort of thing I do want to maybe get a
dive coaster in this Pike they're really
fun to build and um it's always good to
theme them but um I don't think it'll be
something too similar to B
[Music]
1898 okay you don't really work over
there I almost just removed something
that which I didn't have to remove that
was
C thing is these trees are cool and all
but damn they're so large
they just have that perfect color to
them that's just a big quality right
here and does this have random size or
not I think it does but I'm not seeing
too much of a difference
[Music]
there and you can't see of the
river anymore if I place it like that um
a different tree probably I don't really
need to block too much of the view of
whatever is behind
this at least not per se with an
oak and thanks you go uh hitbox I'm not
sure my um and high St by the way my
like twitch is pretty much my go-to sort
of medium for streaming and I at the
moment I'm don't really think I'll ever
be switching to anything else
really uh plus that's where I've
basically achieved the basically
gathered my followers and stuff at this
point H wasn't this one of the megal
themes I'm not sure
though and uh one good reason to not
stream on this thing too much is that I
really need my good music not that Mario
Galaxy is good music I like it but uh
theyit a change a bit of a change with
copyrighted music that would me
over on
YouTube
[Music]
capitalism a short overview of the
entire par that's actually a pretty good
idea I'll try to get the right three in
here and um do
that I think this is actually
the best tree so far no it's not it's
it's not really
that if only the um spices trees were
just a tiny bit smaller that was a tiny
bit of a smaller variant of like the
Hickory or I could just try the Hickory
I think I'll go for the
Hickory and get some other trees in over
here since if like I like um don't
stutter for a second if I place more of
these trees over here just very suddenly
you won't see the um other themes
anymore so that should be good okay uh
so that is that I'm actually bastic save
for a second
[Music]
here Two Steps From Hell music is
amazing yeah but it's also copyright
infringement
intensifies and
um it definitely gets that copyright on
it
I haven't actually seen Francis
Coaster's uh new catwalk set
[Music]
yet um I haven't heard that new album
I've actually never heard of that um
artist and by the way I don't think the
twitch or at least for me the twitch
delay is not too much of a big issue I
don't really mind it that much at least
not
uh much enough to just completely step
over to another different medium
entirely oh this actually looking at it
actually shaping up into a theme par
okay we wanted to do a short little
overview of the park um this is all
still the same just the same old little
entrance area Square except now it has a
trolley track and probably more Flags
because the flags are very important and
um actually some small changes here and
there like this building got some major
revamping uh some different colors I
think too this building also got
revamped does have still a bit of a of a
strange color scheme right
there
ghosts uh I'll keep that in mind um
ghost B
go tips for someone who's just starting
with roller coaster ATT three um most
important thing um definitely said this
before the Dig Vu is intense uh most
important thing is just enjoy it
honestly uh that'll get you fur this
don't push yourself too much but um best
way to learn is to try to copy off of
what other people are doing um not for
really owned projects that you should
show off but if you copy off what other
people are doing then you um do really
learn what they do to achieve certain
looks and it really does help uh in any
case I forgot to pie over there damn I'm
going to have to repair that uh but yeah
this is the main sort of square I was
trying to do that little sort of
overview with the Main Street and all
its buildings uh which leads up to the
big main square of the park from this
sort of main Square you go to all the
different sections in the park itself
which are not going to be quite as
perfectly round and disney-ish but
that's how it's working in its most
basic ways and then we go to the Spanish
from here which is almost finished uh
finished at this
point um just need to sort of work on
the lock FL kind of add some finishing
touches and finish some buildings and
now we're almost there so this is
basically just got a log FL in it little
ship right right there the teacups and a
restaurant there uh from which you have
a bridge going over to the Dutch area
which is what I'm currently working on
where we currently just have this little
ride and the train
station and somewhere around here is
going to have to be the coffee shop very
important and how you go by the
way the Dutch Palace set is an
Abomination it's it's not a good set
definitely not um the name of the park
that I'm currently leaning towards
though um nothing is really officially
There Yet the current project name is
Eurasia Park I know it's a complete and
utter ripoff of Europa Park
um but it's supposed to be more of a bit
of a wink to it since Europa Park is
themed to all the countries in Europe
and this park is going to be themed to
all the countries in
Eurasia uh damn it I forgot there's not
a diagonal version of that
thing um the gardening does I think have
that yeah a couple planters that I might
want to
try I mean this one's pretty damn large
but still be worth a
try I'll see the other ones do
though oh but the other ones don't
really have diagonals at least not all
of
them this one's good
though well don't do that no I think I
want to go with this
one oh yes Europa Park is a really
beautiful Park
and um yeah I do want to get a sort of
comfy look despite how large this park
is especially the Dutch area is starting
to get that for me with like the canals
and the
bridges and um even though it's got a
major like major juer position right
here with like the rural sort of look
over there and the big city over there I
think it still uh made it in a way and
I'm quite happy about that though it's
definitely still a lot of work to still
be done around this sort of area and
among the back of this
because this is definitely at
the moment I need to get to that soon um
yeah really soon actually I'll get to
that right now because I can't look at
that that is just an Abomination right
there um I think I'm just going to do it
in the same way at least finish it semi-
realistic and thanks
forless the Dutch Palace does have a
really good brick texture but now that
was just uh that was just ripped um on
on R of The Flume that was also a good
idea though I'll get to that um actually
right now then we'll uh have it over
with it's actually a much better idea
and though I must add this Flume at the
moment is still very very much in its
work in progress stage kind of like ICT
World um people want to see it but um
there's still a few things to really
work
[Music]
on the music fits perfectly
now and thanks Big R Rick by the
way one thing that it does really have
especially around here is having those
good looks of the um facad in the
distance but as you can see there's
still a lot to be worked on with the
details around the ride itself also the
render distance on that clock is really
bad because with the fov of the on rde
for some reason uh so I'm definitely
there there we go pops out so I'm
definitely going to have to work on that
as well but just need some overall
details around here small animals maybe
um some animatronics small sort of parts
of buildings and
things um I live in a beautiful
beautiful quaint little town in the in
the Netherlands
called it's an absolutely amazing
absolutely amazing
place I won't do any sort of episode or
anything in Dutch since that would
basically rule out the English people
and I don't see much of a point in doing
it the only thing that I really gained
with it is that English people can't
understand me um so I won't do that uh
I still have to remove the brakes
of that
thing H I thought I did
that I'm also I might want to make that
clock also slightly larger still looking
a tiny bit small
though and yeah especially around this
area just like lecking all the details
over here small water fountains like
interactive L flum stuff is also
something that I would really like to
have and uh yeah what he just said the
Dutch language isn't really the most
beautiful language
ever but yeah it's definitely got like I
can see the core here but it's got so
many unfinish thing still I'm not really
going for
it H so the music didn't loop I
suppose H I think and um I'm just seeing
lag on the stream as well too
now uh yeah I do know slip
notot oh God there we go we but I need
to C some music we are on the Lo
flum we are on the Lo flum I'm Rob Alie
I just got my own music I thought I put
it on Loop all there we go nice
stream it I'm just going to keep
that going because we're not going to
keep going for too long here but yeah
that was that that was the L flum and I
really need to finish off these
[Music]
things there is no way that you can
pronounce the town name is V in a not
completely stupid way
way honestly who even came up with
that I mean that's the only thing I have
to do to prove people that to prove to
other people that the Dutch language
isn't exactly the most elegant sounding
language ever
just just name the little city that I
live in oh there you
go and yeah I need to find out how I can
get Splash effects too
since it's a
CT and uh it's even made by me and I
don't know jack about making CTS
it's nothing really to it when it comes
to Splash effects so I really should
look at that as
well I like the restaurant though with
the different facades and stuff it's
still got it
down quite happy with
[Music]
that and you're
welcome my internet speed is really bad
that's the only thing I really need to
say I've got an upload of about 2 megab
and a download of about 25 that was the
wrong audo but it doesn't
matter
[Music]
um go to EUR Asia there we go I can
never find my own sets that is my
[Music]
life such is life you'd
say uh um but there we go and it doesn't
glitch for some reason it really
doesn't no idea how I got that but uh it
doesn't glitch that's
[Music]
cool I like the chimneys a lot too like
I don't know they fit
perfectly and um I'm going to have to
have some sort of little path running
between these
[Music]
buildings
and hi fantasy ATM X by the way I lost
audio wait I really don't have audio
[Music]
anymore and yep I'm going to go back to
Twitch don't worry about that most
[Music]
definitely wait a second what's up with
these placements
all right this probably is
conforming yep probably
is I love the music especially this
track Like I am a complete sucker for
wses ever since roller coaster one
I think it's because of roller coaster
one oh there so many wals in that OSD so
um this is just amazing I don't know
just the the time signature alone just
makes me happy in any case what what
sort of path was I trying to find that
could maybe
work not sure maybe
dutches if I do that it's probably a
better choice to go with this
one
yep
[Music]
oh right yeah it's working fine for
YouTube okay I won't even get to that I
won't even finish that sentence
um I've been on the medium that
I'm using
[Music]
enough
but yeah it's a shame that I can't have
let the bodies hit the floor anymore I
mean what's YouTube isn't even the same
anymore without let the bodies hit the
floor and sound system it's just a
different ball game YouTube is not that
escape for social anxiety ridden nerds
anymore who want to riddle the world
with their notepad tutorials without
making any money it's become a world of
companies and the find Bros running this
commercial
scheme anyway I need to find my curve
point zero there we
go is that the right one looks a bit
[Music]
weird and uh I'm sorry I'm not too
familiar with uh slipnot like whatsoever
I know that they exist and I know a
couple of their songs um but other than
that
nope I usually listen to what mostly I
listen to Wim Temptation
Muse red chili peppers are pretty cool
and radio
head U though I'm starting to discover
blur as well that's probably my um
current sort of
thing thing is what sort of wall should
I get for this oh bugu does it really
even matter anyway uh time to just get
the recallable bad Rock give that a nice
little qu and call it a day
there except we don't because that looks
like
except we take the much better
textures from
Mob M's new textures are absolutely
[Music]
amazing
yeah professionalism and commercialism
and
capitalism just took over YouTube it's
crazy I mean it's not necessarily too
bad of a thing it's just I get nostalgic
many times like thinking about the way
YouTube was like even it's shitty things
seem so amazing right
now
but yeah there's no use in looking back
at Nostalgia also I need to fix that
fence my OCD is severely triggered by
[Music]
that it's memes all the way well it used
to probably be more
memes
[Music]
this song is uh kind of a w as
well that probably explains why it's so
[Music]
good um but yeah pretty much the only
YouTube memes at the moment are just
Montage parodies and I'm not even going
to go into
[Music]
that
internet taking over the radio oh holy
yeah internet is already seeping
into
everything I think I'm just going to go
with the uh this one I know it's always
a safe choice to go with this one though
I would like to change the post just a
tiny bit yeah there we
[Music]
go and yes the old YouTube layouts for
channels were amazing like there was so
much
customization and then at some point
YouTube dropped it and went to like
Channel
One whatever the that was supposed
to mean and like you couldn't customize
anything anymore it's just white and
advertisements much more room for
advertisements and it looks much more
professional like from my um marketing
standpoint it was definitely a good move
by YouTube but I can't help but just be
annoyed by the fact that I used to do I
used to be able to basically change
everything about my layout on YouTube
but now I can't
[Music]
D and fail is now a radio show on BBC
Radio
One
wow and also hi to by the
way H I know corn I did actually
recently listen to an to an album like
cor um it's not entirely my sort of
thing but um I really don't really like
it either it's pretty good though in
that similar style in that similar sort
of vein I'm much more of a fan of System
of a
Down what is actually
um trying to find medium rocks for some
reason I always lose medium rocks I
always start looking in the M section
it's the worst idea ever since it's
wavers but it's like the only waivers
set actually starts off with his
name
but yeah after this I'm really going to
have to call it a day and uh it's going
to be the uh the
stream it's going to be episode 100
longest episode
ever also you don't want to have to have
that similar lock work so close to each
other I'm actually going to change the
uh style and color of the rock work here
since it's uh more Dutch is should also
be a tiny bit more gray stuff I
[Music]
suppose and I would like to finish that
off with one really small rock on this
side that would be
amazing it's going to be hard to find
anything good
but there we go that sort of
works and then I can remove the this
blending
I definit I only know um bullet uh
for My Valentine from that and
[Music]
Disturbed time to spray this it's
an actual grass over
here I know I am such a Slowpoke when it
comes to building whenever I'm streaming
I just can't
multitask
whatever um so just like check out what
people are saying and respond and help
and then do roller coaster K three for a
bit and it doesn't really work out too
well but um I think we're getting there
with this little
thing plus I'm themeing back sections
that I really don't have to do just
going to probably put more foliage over
here and I really not do much else with
that I think so yeah I definitely
probably want to have some foliage
behind this just to make sure that you
don't see all the Spanish stuff going on
in the background
anymore I don't know about the
advertisements being mostly on the
popular videos but it might be that way
could very well be like
that that's one thing that I dislike
about YouTube though a lot is the
already enormous channels are just
getting completely forced to everyone
and just grow bigger and bigger while
the really small channels just don't
even have a chance to get anywhere
unless you're either helped by a really
large Channel or you start I don't know
bitching reviews by making standard
Minecraft Let's Plays and pumping out
10,000 videos a
day
H actually that's it doesn't entirely
cover the entire thing that I would like
to cover
there and another Hickory would actually
not even do
that yeah I tree with a quartile
placement would
[Music]
though but yeah why do you even find
those around this world I'm going to see
if uh ging 2 actually has some good
stuff actually yeah ging 2 has that one
Ash that could
[Music]
work come here
cutie there we go and uh then I still
need to get something behind this to
cover that up and then that should
provide a bit of a barrier between the
two areas without being too blatantly a
complete
Forest uh the rock set is called waer
medium rocks it's absolutely amazing
set probably my favorite rock set out
there wber does have another set which
is called we large rocks which it does
work pretty well with um but in my
opinion it's got slightly less good
textures and um the rocks are really
large like the size for these rocks are
absolutely perfect to do anything
with I can't Professor Sycamore is one
Professor but that's very off topic I
don't know if I can get that thing in
safely there and just do it like
that but I think it does
work I think I can just go with that um
just to be on the safe side see if
there's anything else that I can try
here I would like to try the Hickory and
see how that works I mean the U the
Birch that's why I had in
mind you can never have enough
Birches um actually the Birch works all
right as
well
I just think that the uh what's it
called Sycamore is slightly better since
it's
darker does a better overall job at
covering the area behind it and there we
go so that's going to be that still want
to add some beach cross around
that uh I have actually looked at that
town um as a tiny bit of inspiration
from
it but honestly the Dutch area is pretty
much built at this point already and
I've seen many sort of Dutch things that
I could get in there but in the end just
settled with like the very most famous
things uh so this is based of the zans H
but also in a way after marus since it's
very similar and of course Amsterdam
couldn't not have
that
[Music]
and there were other things also that I
found in Holland that I might want to
try to get in um but in the end I just
really had to settle on just a few
things plus it needs to be uh realistic
with the other areas as well I don't
have every single well-known thing from
Spain in the Spanish area
[Music]
either software engineering major all
right well still I know major in it and
it's still interesting to talk about I
mean figuring we're still on YouTube
over here and uh well if you're on
YouTube quite often often enough to find
my shitty tiny Channel then uh you're
probably pretty passionate about that
whether you're majored in it or
not feel like the class kind of around
that
if I can get it in over
here not really just ends up looking
weird yep that'll be
that should definitely see if I can get
some read in there but that'll really be
the uh the end of this video or um
stream I
mean um there's no room really left for
his Farms or anything like that so I
don't think I'll really be able to cover
any sort of Dutch Farm areas or tulip
fields as much as I would like it to be
there um like really the only sort of
thing that I can do is since I'm going
to have to have a playground over here
and a windmill over there is have a tiny
tiny little sort of tulip field in
between that but other than that I don't
really have any space for that in this
area now I need to
find G's harb set there we
go oh yes yes there one right
here oh damn it those read are way too
[Music]
large um still too large actually
D so high like I'd be all right with
that but you can't really exactly have
forests of reads in roller coaster
3 um plus placement isn't the best thing
either
do actually uh do like that yeah that
seems to be the best sort of thing to do
though um so there we
go did get quite a bit done for this
little area over here
um I would actually say that from this
standpoint still need to get some lights
in here and some benches but definitely
almost
there the way I discovered your channel
is I was about to clean the dishes and
figured I'd like to have a live stream
playing in the background scrolled
around YouTube gaming for wait so that
thing is actually a
thing oh wow that is really
awesome so
so damn YouTube gaming is actually
getting used and you can actually find
people with that that's actually
good yeah that's actually really cool
since that is one thing that I always
felt about YouTube it's really hard as a
just starting person to get anywhere so
that's streaming could really help with
that oh that's really awesome to hear in
any case I am going to really have to
wrap this up damn it um do I say it
do I say there are barely even any Dutch
people on here but
um you know that there's a time to come
and there's a time to go and the time to
go has come so
um I'm going to have to end this like
every single thing
ever um I hope that I will not get
completely raped by Nintendo please
don't do that Nintendo I love you too
much for
that
um yeah I actually does make sense that
gaming YouTube is being used like that I
never get to the town of urant that's
just I don't know what I would even want
to do over there the big white building
building in the Italian
area uh I'm not sure which one but um
I'm I still need to do the back sides of
these buildings in any case um about the
front like the front facades of them I
am pretty happy about that uh in any
case that will really be it I'm really
bad at ending things on time I'm also
really bad at starting things on time so
I suppose that kind of evens it out but
I'm going to go guys so thank you all
for watching and
um I'll see you later I'll it in and see
you space Cowboys now ending the stream
should just be the normal kind of thing
at least the ending shouldn't be as
awkward as the beginning they can't get
very mad if you don't monetize I didn't
set this uh stream to be monetized so um
then uh I should be all right this is
actually Roller Coaster Tycoon 3 by the
way um it says where does that actually
say
it um doesn't even say it anyway I can't
even see it's it's getting too late for
me I start voice cracking and it's
it's not good oh go ict3 uh that's the
game that we're playing here in any case
that the game that I was playing cuz I'm
going to go and I already did my outro
so
um Peace